One cannot discuss anti-lock braking without asking whether or not
such an improved safety feature actually saves human lives.
Some researchers argue that humans tend to stick to a certain riskiness of the behavior.
The envelope of what can be considered risky behavior is pushed up
with introduction of anti-lock braking.
And many drivers are going to stay with the original level of riskiness, which means that
with the introduction of anti-lock braking systems, they are going to drive faster and brake harder
relying on the improved brakes.
In the end, it all boils down to saying that psychology matters.
To improve safety, we cannot only look at technology or to cite an example from history--
when your ship is supposedly unsinkable, why should you care about icebergs?